nine months ago it seemed like everyone
was in the froth they were just uh fomo
and into every asset class we saw
everything from trading cards to stocks
uh to you know little nfts all the way
on down uh here we are nine months later
and not so much fomo not so much froth
uh what happened and why exactly
did this occur
the baby came pump you can relate right
you know leading up to the base all
excitement and everything's euphoric and
you got all the presents coming in
and then
bang
you know no sleep
and uh you know things are a lot tougher
on the other side now i i think what it
is
is
the little boy who cried wolf
okay right when the boy cries wolf and
the wolf doesn't come everybody says oh
i won't listen the next time and cries
wolf and then and i think this time the
fed actually
turned into the wolf you know it's
interesting when when powell
came in
you know he was jerome the hawk
you know he all the cartoons were him
with the hawk body and
and then he became jay j-a-y
the dove
right when trump kind of put you know
the needle in and said hey you got to
help me with the market and he backed
off in 18 on on his hey i'm going to
raise interest rates
and the market rallied well by 2020
i mean he was jay just the letter j the
pusher in the hoodie on the corner
passing out you know hits the steroids
to everybody
so
i don't think anyone thought
jerome the hawk would come back
i don't think anybody thought
the markets
would also
do his job for him
in the sense that by the time he raised
the second 50 basis points up to 75
the market had already tightened two and
a half points i mean we had the greatest
tightening of liquidity
in the last hundred years
so i think that's what changed so this
is a great point in that uh a lot of
folks will argue that uh the way that we
talk about inflation can create
inflation so if everyone starts yelling
and screaming inflation's coming
inflation's coming then actually some
business owners or maybe even many of
them will raise prices in anticipation
and that in turn creates inflation
it seems like
the fed tried to do the opposite and
talk the market down and kind of talk
tough
and the longer that they did that
without actually raising rates to your
point there was a little bit of like the
boy cried wolf
do you think that there's any weight or
ability for them to actually talk tough
enough to get the market to move or does
the market only care about actions
it's the perfect it's the perfect
question
here's here's what i've been saying for
the last couple months is
you know the fed
didn't create
the
inflation that we're all feeling
uh and they can't fix it
right how many basis points
are going to restore
the supply chains in china how many
basis points of tightening are going to
get all those ships stranded off the
ports to unload and reload to come back
here
how many
you know basis points
is going to stop the craziness on people
locking down and halting parts of the
economy
no way
and so that's the first part and i will
also make the case that
the inflation that we see
isn't
inflation the way most people are
talking about it trying to compare this
to the 70s
this is nothing like the 70s right 70s
was about demand pole inflation where
there was excess demand and limited
supplies and then then really a big
problem with the iran-contra scandal and
the saudi pullback in oil
and oil prices spiked and then on top of
it
there was a built-in
problem in the way they measured cpi
back there back then in that it double
counted
uh
interest rates and
house prices and so volcker who you know
everybody says oh he beat the you know
beat inflation he was actually causing
the problem he was looking at bad data
raising interest rates which was then
feeding back into the data raising so it
was
he didn't really beat it per se it was
just it got so high that people just
said oh geez i'm done right i won't do
anything at 20 prime rate
the difference is this time we don't
have demand pull inflation we don't have
good demographics we don't have uh low
levels of debt so people can lever up
and start businesses we have the exact
opposite we have crappy demographics you
know people turn 65 every single day 10
000 of them in this country every single
day for the next seven years
and 65 to 85 year old people don't spend
a lot they don't you know uh they're not
as productive the way we measure
productivity
we have way too much debt debt is
deflationary not inflationary
the real problem we have is currency
debauchement
what happened two years ago
is we had the
buffoon move by whoever the wephites to
lock down the world
absolute insanity i mean literal
insanity
and because of that
the reaction from global central bankers
was print print print printer and print
because the cult of kelton right the
stephanie kelton you know modern
monetary theory people modern monetary
madness people
decided that oh we can print as much as
we want and it won't matter well no of
course it matters
right you used to live down here in
north carolina where i am now
houses houses are up 40 40 in 12 months
my house did not grow it did not get
more efficient it actually cost me money
i have to put money into the house to
keep it a certain level
it's not worth 40 more the currency in
which i value it is worth 40 less
that's not inflation the way they want
us to believe
that inflation is good for us that
prices rise in a controlled way that's
just currency debasement